une ministre pour lancer le programme
action coeur de ville chargée de la
cohésion des territoires jacqueline
gourault était à nevers ce lundi un
déplacement pour officialiser la
participation de l'agglomération à la
démarche gouvernementale 222 villes en
france sont concernées dont neuf en
bourgogne et le dispositif laisse une
grande liberté aux initiatives de chacun
originalité c'est que l'état accompagne
des projets locaux
il n'ya c'est un système souple il n'y a
pas de règle qui partent du sommet pour
s'appliquer sur les territoires ce sont
les territoires qui montrent leur projet
le programme se fonde sur un budget
global de 5 milliards d'euros sur cinq
ans dans un premier temps nevers devrait
bénéficier d'une enveloppe de près de
deux millions et demi d'euros de quoi
accompagner de nombreuses initiatives
dont certaines déjà bien engagé il ya
des actions autour du commerce à
mobilité la navette autonome que les
nivernais vont pouvoir découvrir dans
quelques semaines sur l'espace public à
deux verres en décembre janvier
et puis la rénovation des espaces
publics et tout l'aspect logement va
être très fortement développée par
contre sur les fiches actions qui vont
être présentés en janvier 2019 le but
enrayer le déclin du centre-ville ces
dernières années population en baisse
vacance des logements disparition de
boutiques un cercle vicieux contre
lequel doit lutter progressivement
action coeur de ville c'est un
accélérateur
là pour la ville de nevers et la vie
commerçante
on sait que dans la deuxième partie il y
aura aussi plus de fiches concernant le
commerce pur en réalité donc voilà la
dynamique est vraiment enclenché fois la
poursuivre nevers a notamment choisi de
miser sur l'innovation et l'amélioration
du cadre de vie en espérant à terme
atteindre son objectif ramener des
habitants et de l'activité en
centre-ville